I don't know if you've noticed but the
world is becoming a little obsessed with
AI artificial intelligence I saw an
advert last week selling a vacuum
cleaner telling me that it was developed
using AI technology and if that's not
going to be the end of the world I don't
know what is and studios are desperately
scrambling to get the next big TV show
on their screens that will have ai at
its core and one of them is a show you
know very well welcome to scite Che your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel so a couple
of months ago I told you that NBC was
thinking about bringing back some of its
more classic TV shows that those shows
were going to exist within universe and
have crossovers the D shows were going
to appear on the NBC Network and it was
going to be very much like a Marvel
style project where they would have the
TV series running um alongside each
other say 10 episodes and then you have
a couple of months and it'd be the next
series would come back so each so would
have like one season a year um and then
there'd be lots of Crossovers and then
they'd maybe build up towards a TV movie
and all of this was going to go on
peacock what shows well Night Rider the
at Airwolf and the $6 billion doll man
with a B Because $6 million doll isn't
enough money anymore now I was told you
about that a few months ago because this
was one of those ideas that was being
bounced around by Executives over at NBC
initially it seemed like one of those
things that it was just because a bunch
of Executives really didn't have much to
do so they were sort of sat around
thinking about what would they do once
they were allowed to get back to work
and somebody came up with this idea
pitched it to Upper executive NBC and
they were asked to start running with it
now my sources have told me that the
conversations have developed somewhat
even just over the last couple of months
and somebody now has said that should be
an AI show we should make that about
AI now what do we think about that get
into the comments now before I keep
talking but I know what my initial
reaction was my initial reaction was oh
for God's sake but then I actually
thought about it now first of all I have
to tell you about the 18am NBC don't
actually own the rights to the 18am
anymore I think it's Disney that do but
anyway they don't own the rights now
there were some exploratory
conversations to see if they could get
the 18 within this new universe because
those are the four shows really that
when people think about the 80s that's
what they tend to think about they tend
to you know it's a team Airwolf Night
Rider the six6 billion dollar man and
maybe like Street Hawk so they wanted
those four shows to exist within this
universe
together however the thinking has
changed a little bit and it seems to be
at the moment that they would still be
very interested in the 18 being a part
of this but they're not too worried if
they're not now I'm speculating a little
bit here because I don't know for
certain but I'm thinking if they are
going to go this route of an AI Space TV
show that the the core of whatever the
main overarching story is going to be
some sort of artificial intelligence
then I could see where the $ six6
billion dollar man maybe Airwolf and
definitely Night Rider remembering kit
is actually AI it's that's what kit is
fit together the technology I could
imagine them being able to write story
lines in really easily I don't quite see
how the a te fit into that so that would
be my suggestion that that that may be
what they're thinking look it's going to
be expensive to get the at and actually
does it fit in what we're thinking to do
in anyway so maybe they bring in Street
Hawk instead I'd be okay with that the
actual pilot for Street Hawk is on
YouTube you can watch it for free go and
have a look it's actually much better
than I remember I watched it when I did
my back in a couple of months ago and I
couldn't get out of bed for three days
it was really good we are going to be
seeing a lot of TV shows and movies Etc
with AI in their core we're already
seeing it let's be honest you know like
the most recent Mission Impossible and
it gets brought up in loads of TV shows
and things we're going to see it even
more because it really is in the center
of people's Consciousness at the moment
I've actually listened to Sam Ismail
recently talking about Battle Star
Galactic and he was even talking about
how AI is in the cultural soup at the
moment and that was going to be far more
the core of his new battl Star Galactica
TV show so everybody seems to be
thinking along the same lines even
though Ai and artificial intelligence
has really been in our science fiction
for pretty much ever it's actually
starting to get to a point where it's
becoming a reality where it's actually
starting to be seen by sort of normies
in their normal day-to-day life AI is
everywhere so it is going to peque the
interest of not just the hardcore sci-fi
fans but the wider Community or at least
that's the
thinking if you're enjoying the video
don't forget to like subscribe and hit
that Bell notification so you miss none
of our new videos and most importantly
leave a comment it's a community after
all we want to know what you think too
so is this project actually developing
is it actually moving down the road is
this actually going from an idea to a
plan well my source said look don't get
ahead of yourself this is very much at
the stage of Executives and a couple of
creative people over at NBC talking
about whether they think this is a good
idea or not and if they do it how do
they do it the next stage would be to
ask for production companies potentially
to come in and Pitch ideas for it so
basically the studio has to decide what
they want to do or what they're thinking
they'd like to do they then ask
companies to look hey we're thinking
about doing this if you got any ideas
pitch those ideas to us and then they
would maybe go away and develop
something for NBC so we're really only
at sort of like part one of this story
it may take a little while for this to
actually move forwards but the
interesting thing is here that they're
starting to really build up a picture of
what they think they would like they
want a TV show with AI at its core Night
Rider in particular would really fit
that bill but then you throw in the
nostalgic excitement of bringing back
Airwolf and the $6 billion doll man as
well that could really give them a
franchise that they could build off a
bit of nostalgia is very popular at the
moment the other thing that my source
said to me was look peard season 3 was a
Nostalgia Fest it was fan service in the
extreme and people loved it the studios
noticed we're going to be getting a lot
more of that in the future until we get
sick of it and then we hate it and then
we wish they hadn't done it in the first
place but hey for the meantime we might
get Night Rider back which I think would
be okay so a storyline with AI at its
core a talking car a very Advanced I
imagine is going to end up being a
talking helicopter
yeah and the $6 billion doll man which I
think would epitomize that because he is
man and machine it could be a little bit
like the remake of Robocop you know the
one a little while ago of Michael Keaton
that was terrible um the whole premise
of that story was that RoboCop had been
turned into a cyborg but actually um the
computer was faster than him so what he
didn't realize was the computer was
actually taken over when he sort of went
into kill mode I actually think that
could be something interesting done
better than the RO RoboCop version
because the RoboCop is terrible movie
would be something interesting for the
bionic man that where is the man and
where is the machine and where is the
are the lines between the two blurred I
actually think that would be a very
interesting metaphor for sort of culture
and society today where Technologies
become so intrinsic in our day-to-day
lives that really sometimes you have to
wonder where do I end and my phone
start I not H certain some times
particularly my teenage sons who
actually I think are fused to their
phones I mean literally so I actually
think this is a really interesting idea
but what do you think get into the
comments would you love to see these
shows come back and if the studios
really are looking for an AI based
franchise does this sort of thing make
sense to you get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also you can
go to patreon.com citrek where most of
our new videos Premiere first and you
get to see them without the adverts
finally you can go to
s.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on a lot of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time